here we are we're talking about this
game from Tata Steel chess between
Wesley Show and Levon Aronian as I was
saying it's very exciting what we saw
has switched federations to the United
States and now he's kinda pulled it up
to as high as number six in the world
throughout this tournament and Tata
Steel and yeah it's great to see another
player along with kicker Nakamura up
there in the number in the top ten
representing the United States I'm he's
having a really good tournament and I
encourage you to check out some of his
videos from the livestream there with a
grandmaster yassir's heroine who's
coming in after me actually because
Wesley does a really good job of kind of
talking about his own moves in this
particular game Wesley was playing ye
and as we discussed he played the Scots
instead of the Ray Lopez which is more
typical I know a lot of you know there
was an interesting at a Wesley so game
actually where he played on the black
side of double King pawn and it was kind
of a weird joke Oh piano line so a lot
of players are taking a cue from Magnus
Carlsen and just playing weird stuff
these days which is really a pleasant to
see because it's like you don't know
really what to expect
so after were here to guard the e5 pawn
and now Queen takes a7 is its potential
which is what happened and now we just
get like a super weird position so wait
making sure to like close things down
here with a move f5 I'm not letting
black just kind of come in with the King
and after Knight to f4 white played
Queen f3
and now after Queen f7 g3 Knight h5 now
what do you think wait to play here kind
of a wacky position where both players
just squeeze your hand if you don't mind
and both players on Castle both layers
with pieces and very strange positions
but 94 is definitely an idea coming up
for later because it does seem like we
need to get this White Knight developed
in order to get this Bishop to that
before it looks like a nice square
provided that we have a good defense to
on d5 here I'm sure your your thing I'm
opening your night on g5 which looks
very dangerous indeed so I think that if
we play an idea for they might have to
play Bishop e7 to stop that but white
started with something else more forcing
to get gone yeah he just thought it
would be ship to e2 just attacking the
knight on age 5 and now after Knight f6
your move Knight e4 doesn't look quite
as appealing but white had another super
aggressive idea mine
yeah
what's that yeah yes g4 was played
exactly so just g4 just kind of like
trying to come at in before LaVon has
time they can tolerate the position in
Castle so kind of act like that
so here d5
what other moves would you be looking at
in this position
the ship before that makes some sense so
that I am a little I'm pretty nervous
about g5r because I because I don't
think that Bishop takes g2 is gonna
really help you that much I mean I
probably would look at age six it's true
I don't know who said that just because
it's a g5 doesn't kind of annoying idea
although h6 creates all sorts of
weaknesses so d5 definitely the most
logical move here to try to open up the
position and allow black and a secondary
retreat square for the knight right so
in this position what you did follow it
up with g5 and then the position is
pretty messy indeed and after E for
attacking the Queen Queen h3 what do you
guys think a little bit in analyze this
position if you look at these variations
on chat space or with a computer engine
or some other annotation it just seems
like Levon Aronian played like a
horrible move here and you can't
understand why but when you actually try
to study the position yourself you
realize how complicated it is and how
easy it is to make a mistake and how
obviously you know such a strong player
usually wouldn't make a mistake but it's
not as absurd as if you flatten
everything out and just like study with
a computer and then all right so that's
why it's really good to get your hands
dirty sometimes my brother Greg and the
famous trainer Greg hide out of have an
exercise where they encourage kids and
adults who are learning to get better to
play guess the move it's not very fancy
you just put your tough space into
training mode and you guess every move
that the guy played it's kind of
time-consuming but what it does is it
gives you a good appreciation for how
difficult it is to find one good move
after another so here move they were
Levon Aronian played it was considered
double question mark 97
the correct move which I think most of
you played Knight d7 Knight G the dog
seven and we'll see why unfortunately
the problem with Knight g8 here is that
after Bishop h5g sakes now we can do
what well we can play pawn to g6 even
though our Queen on h3 is in take we're
taking on f7 and the night on g8 it's in
take but one of the real key things here
is that black doesn't have time now to
play pawn takes g6 because of what Queen
takes see a winning so it's funny that
you would think that Bishop uncovering
an attack on the Queen would be a good
thing but it turns out to be a bad thing
because this variation is totally lost
whereas if you would put your knight on
as d7 notice that after Bishop h5 g6 now
white cannot simply play pawn takes g6
right because now pawn takes g6 is
possible because there's no more Queen
takes ea right so kind of simple when
you lay it out all like that but when
you're playing during the game and
you're also looking at all sorts of
other variations like g6 and all this
other stuff it can become kind of tricky
what they say about calculation in
general is that it's not usually the
fact that people don't see deeply enough
but rather that they don't see the
horizontally and off or thickly enough
so they might see five moves ahead but
they forget that on the third move there
was an extra option that is more likely
to be an error in calculation than not
seen long enough right that's why they
say wrong variation long long variation
wrong variation because generally people
are more making mistakes and not looking
at enough candidate moves not in looking
at one candidate move not long enough so
nice
and now after Bishop h5g six takes on g6
Wesley Shaw is simply going to win this
game because he's up a piece right
so very nice win by Wesley so in the
fact that in the opening he came with
some new ideas and it worked out well
one of the nice things about showing
your opponent new ideas in the opening
is that a lot of times they're
unprepared and that causes them to make
more mistakes
so chess especially at the lower levels
is all about inducing your opponent to
make more mistakes and that means
playing openings that can induce
mistakes playing good positional moves
you know a lot of people say chess is
99% tactics
therefore strategy and openings aren't
that important I actually disagree with
that the reason I disagree with that is
that even though most games are decided
by tactics at the amateur level and even
many professional level games a lot of
those tactics are set up by strong
openings and strong positional chess so
if you don't you know have good openings
and good sense of strategy even if your
tactics are twenty five hundred on chess
calm you might not have that many
opportunities to unleash those tactics
so it is very important tactics but it's
not the only thing so let's take a look
at one of the most critical games as we
congratulate Wesley so on his great
result of course today was the first
really nasty day for Wesley so and that
he was you know treated to quite a long
marathon battle against um uh nice
Tyrion eventually went down but was
lauded by many for his fighting spirit
so certainly lots of great things to
come from Wesley and I know some of you
in the audience actually watched that
game which I find pretty impressive well
now we're going to look at one of the
games that of course everybody's waiting
for number one and number two Cara Juana
and Carlsen facing off I love this game
Magnus Carlsen playing black it was a
really nice game some of you might
recognize it I'm Kara Juana of course
Catalonian yourself to like the clearer
number two in the world after his
remarkable result here in st. Louis at
the Ziegfeld cop since then of course he
has not been able to replicate in
success but who can I mean something 7ml
in that field is uh you know not likely
to be repeated anytime soon right so in
this game he's playing white and I was
watching young Gustafson on chess 24
annotated this game and he said right
off the bat he was a little bit
surprised by Carolina's choice here with
Bishop e5 which is a very nice move it's
a good move in fact some people if
they're playing for instance the
accelerated dragon they avoid playing
knight c6 year specifically because they
don't want to play Bishop e5 so they
might play g6
or they might try to transpose in this
fashion a cob with a six all of these
are usually designed because Bishop b5
is a decent move it's like almost like
playing the word Lopez against the
Sicilian right it's very positional and
kind of a nice idea for a white by Yan
was like well Cara Wan is known for
being a great calculator and he's known
for having great opening preparation so
he was a little surprised to see him
play the more strategic approach against
Carlsen of course hindsight being 20/20
and predicted iron but I already say it
makes sense I mean if you look at
Carolina's wins of a Singh field cup you
saw a lot of amazing calculation an
amazing opening preparation those were
the two things are really marked I think
a theme in his victory is in Singh field
so g6 this is all kind of well known and
it looks pretty nice for ye but at the
same time black has Q Bishop so white
has a superior structure Knight takes e5
in this position can be met by Knight a
c4 so pick typical tactical
justification but if we want to talk
about this position strategically well
why do you think the move a3 might be
made in this position for one thing
that's what you're preventing before for
instance b5 would be even if we suppose
black plays Queen e7 and white plays
like just some random move of course
he's not gonna play King H want but b5
would be a positional blunder in fact
because this pawn now is a quite weak
and the square is weak as well so I
don't think that black-white is ever
worried about this pawn coming to b4
it's like the only thing that kind of
Salvage is these this constellation is
the fact that it's like not that easy to
attack c6 so even though these pawns are
doubled it's not really bad furthermore
there's often some nice ideas
maneuvering ideas here particularly for
this black knight if I give you a bunch
of moves to maneuver that Black Knight
where we do maneuver it too well there's
actually a couple possibilities but
there's one that I'm thinking of in
particular each Knight f4 is the quicker
line but if I gave you even more moves
what might you do yeah eight where yes
EAC 76 d4 right and then you can really
see that like these double pawns are not
so bad right like of course again I'm
just giving you a bunch of moves to
illustrate a point now we can really see
like oh this is okay these double pawns
are not really bad pawns right so it's
not even as much of the doubled pawns in
this position that give white something
to chew on
it's more like just a general potential
expansion and that's why when white
plays a3 he's actually thinking about
playing the move before even though you
know at first glance you might say well
why would we want to do that because
those black pawns are double well they
are doubled but they're not that easy to
play against words after you played
before now you're hitting c5 and if
there's a captain on via four d4 is
suddenly a potential for white as well
so that's all are some of the strategic
ideas in this position and as you can
see compared
the open Sicilian very strategic battle
right although it does get pretty wild
so instead in 98 okay like see after
position we just get back to the real
gain and now here
Carlson actually made the move Queen to
be one I mean Cara no sorry
Fabiano played the move community one
with the idea of getting beforehand and
so now we do have to remove Knight to
age five trying to get a King side
attack because it seems evident that
wait is gonna have an advantage on the
Queen side after before so black just
wants to get some counter play at the
risk of majorly weakening his position
right so I wouldn't say he's like going
quite for broke but if he doesn't get
some good play going his position could
be quite weak especially with this
bishop here on g7 now as you can see
it's not so pretty well blacks actually
in this position I understand from a
strategic point of view you want to play
Queen takes e5 but there are a couple
issues with that one is that generally
black once they keep his Queen on e7 to
try to support the g5 move and get a
really quick King side attack because as
usual with attacking time is of the
essence you can't just sit around and
take all day annoying it cuz um bad
things are gonna happen then but there's
also another reason that this could be a
little bit problematic now in this
particular position it doesn't seem like
it's a big deal
but I would also be a little bit worried
about this type of idea of Knight g5 and
Queen b3 check I think here it's not
quite working because after King H 895
you just go back to e7 and now white is
just wasted time but it's definitely
something to keep in mind
there is a potential scorn before it's
true that could become a problem yeah um
actually yeah because I mean well you
did the thing is that's a little slow in
it I was thinking unites a four with the
idea Bishop before but you know that
doesn't really work out so well because
just have four Queenie seven Bishop b4
c5 and you just like wasted a bunch of
time well yeah I mean Trading Queens is
certainly gonna be a bit of a win for
Wyatt right no well the Treaty of Queens
will be good for will be good for white
because why do you think it would be
good for a black betray Queens and we're
gonna see actually this theme again and
again in this game the trading Queen
theme which is a huge theme in chess
because when somebody is trying to
attack you a lot of the time the key
idea is to try to trade off Queens or at
least keep that threat of trading Queens
so that they can't attack that well but
why were you thinking the opposite I
think you had a reason
so you're thinking about the two bishops
which are usually going in the endgame
that is usually true but here the
problem is like suppose the one problem
is right away we can't really trade
Queens in our own terms because we
certainly don't want them to play Queen
takes e5 because that would just be a
disaster so we have to kind of take and
that opens up this work on the a file
which is already in the wing and then
you know your idea of brick da de bishop
fa the poem is non- taking you on e5 so
this Bishop g7 is kind of tied down this
position looks actually pretty bad for
back because my own play is quite easy
for right you know I'm gonna play rook
a4 and work a1 and I don't even think
you're going to have an easy time
defending this you're probably gonna
have to play a six but then that's gonna
weaken this it's not gonna be fun
this was gonna be a brutal defense
brutal unpleasant defensive task so
instead black took with the pawn keep
Queens on the board get g5 in so Bishop
Bishop e6 Queen a4 kind of trying to hit
c6 which is the weakness that was
created you know hammer on a different
weakness on c5 but kind of distracting
his pieces so as you can see magnets
just kind of continues with his
attacking ideas here
but has he gone too far because house e5
is hanging with the threat of trading
Queens well we're gonna find out now
after Queen takes c5 certainly black
does not want to trade Queens because
then the situation won't be pretty at
all right so that's why this is coming
up again and again in this game it's
really key that we don't trade Queens
there that's something that you
sometimes see it weak players do in this
position they play Queen takes e5 and
bicha takes f3 and try to get some
compensation I know most of you in this
class are too strong to consider that
but notice that for instance you're too
strong to consider that in a standard
time control game because you can kind
of like sit back and say hey I don't
want to trade Queens in this position
take yourself in the blitz tournament
you're playing tonight when you only
have 23 seconds left on the clock I know
that everybody when they have that
little time has like accidentally traded
Queens when they have an attack so it
just happens
of course Queen f6 even in a 1-minute
game Magnus Carlsen would play Queen SX
he's not trading Queens
so after Knight H to Magnus to move some
of you might have seen this game and I
applied your chess erudition but those
who haven't let's try to think what
black played here cuz basically white
wants to shut down the attack black to
move what would you do is black let's
take a let's take a minute to think
about it for those of you haven't seen
it
yeah
black to move here no you didn't play
Queen h4 well once the night goes h2 now
White has a possibility of trying to
really shut the door and some a blacks
attacking in pieces attacking
possibilities with the move f3
so here no so here we're two black play
so black did play f3 here which it first
looks like it's not possible because of
Knight takes d4 right but now after
Queen g6 well white pretty much has to
play at first it well you did actually I
mean if you can't really play Knight e3
because if he plays 93 now black has a
couple of good ways to play ana what do
you think Bach could play a night at
four looks like a really good move
Bishop h6 also looks pretty good by the
way [ __ ] of eight six threatening
Bishop takes you three in Queen G to
mate but Knight f4 is also looking
really good and if white were to play
for instance g3 in that position what
would black do in this position so g3
what would like to raise your hand yeah
check on you too and then after King age
2 exactly so that is over so we can't do
that in this position in general just
looks pretty busted because you can't do
that you're gonna have to let g2 fall
and just looks pretty over so instead
Carlsen Carolina had this idea planned
out that after Queen g7 after Queen g6
he could defend in this position with
the move Queen East 7 which is that
perfect example of trade Queen's get out
of Dodge right so that's what this move
is all about if we trade Queens here
maybe you will be able to survive right
so again if Queen takes g4
now what can we do exactly Queen g5
forcing the trade of Queens right now
it's absolutely forced to trade Queens
because otherwise they're gonna lose on
h5 so you have to trade Queens and that
was basically what white wanted game
turned out a little bit differently and
that he started with pawn takes detail
attacking the rook on F lon rook to be
one and now Queens you far so again
White's idea is what again we still need
to trade off those Queens otherwise the
attack is going to be devastating so
bringing the Queen into the attack is an
idea that people are always talking
about but bringing into the the Queen
into the defense is also very important
Fabiano Quran in this game really
showing his defensive skills here and
making this clever queen maneuver now do
you guys see any way of course the world
champion this position after getting
this great attack and kind of breaking
open black White's King is gonna be
looking for any way to keep Queens on
the board and keep the attack going but
not that easy to do what would be like
the first move you would look at here
for black to try to accomplish that and
and hit another attacking point you
might look at Queen h3 although you
can't take on g2 you also might look at
what other move Queen f3 you might look
at there's a move that kind of attacks
even more things I would certainly look
at Queen e2 because that move looks like
it texts a lot of stuff right you can't
even play Queen takes G - because you're
a bishop on g2 is hanging right so this
move looks very very dangerous you
obviously can't take on g2 with the king
because if rook takes f2 or Queen takes
f2 so White's left with only one move
here that saves the game and this is why
again the theme is coming up same thing
that we've been talking about
yeah
Queen III we wanted to read those
Queen's right and so black would go back
to g4 with the cheeky idea of just
playing God anything but probably night
at four looks like pretty brutal all
right like if we get night at four in in
this position that's gonna be the end of
the game right so therefore a white
would have to play what now back to g5
you've got to do it and so Magnus if you
wanted to you just take a draw with
Queen e2 Queen e3 well played game shake
hands good job right so that's how the
game probably ended right no no no no
Magnus Carlsen of course famous for
always trying to squeeze something out
of anything if you look at his games
you'll see that theme again and again
and again very famously in the scene
filled Cup not this year but in well not
2014 but in 2013 the first edition he
could have won the tournament in his
last round against Levon Aronian
by making a draw and instead he won that
game so he could have won the first
prize and locked up 50k and instead he
kept going to get the full point so
careless and really very well known for
that so he act we asked in this position
he said not to a draw but to a queen
trade so he said ok maybe I have some
chances in this position after Queen
takes g5 Bishop takes g5 even though it
looks like my opponents likely you're
gonna recapture on g2 soon I still have
a lot of potential energy in my pieces
and there's some little bit of discord
ination hereby White's part right well
you know I think it's a very I think if
you look at it visually I can see why
you might think that because the bishop
on g7 looks bad but I'm unfortunately I
think this position that's a little
early to think about generalizations
looks because there's still a lot of
tactics here especially after Magnus is
next move
there's still a lot of there's still
some tactics that's the thing about end
games like it's definitely a lot more
strategic than middle games but don't be
fooled there's still plenty of tactics
and then games and we are gonna see that
in this game exactly that's why if you
look at it in general terms you might
think White's going well but what move
does black have to kind of like keep the
tactics fly and keep the initiative
going
that's right Knight at port because and
now in this position we're defending the
pawn on g2 and now actually Carolina's
best move in this position is to just
played king h2 to just stop Knight h3
check winning the bishop right but
instead Carolina takes my f4 and the
idea now is that we'll Magnus's idea is
that there's no time for wait to take on
g2 cuz this [ __ ] money one isn't a I
mean the work on a1 isn't a so that
that's what keeps me positioning kind of
interesting but Carolina did take on g2
with the idea that now that now after f3
check King f1 maybe if Bishop to a1 he
thought that perhaps you could round up
this pawn on it on e3 with King e1 King
d2 King III so perhaps black would be
doing well they are too but Carlton
played a different move in this position
so he decided that [ __ ] of takes a one
might not give him enough so he decided
to play and even more kind of striking
beautiful move here which you probably
will know from my if you listen to any
of my commentaries on the US Chess
Championship because I'm always talking
about this idea right the rover what
it's a rover stand for
that's right work up and over and hear
the pun on that three even though it's
an end game with very few pieces the
point enough to recreate some
checkmating possibilities for black so
the move rook to f4 is what Magnus
played with the idea that we're kate's
for Ricketts one would be mating right
so white actually has to be careful here
about getting checkmated and of course
there's also combinations of just
playing Bishop takes a one or it takes a
one work h1 just winning a rough so this
move completely putting on the pressure
for instance like if we were just to try
to ignore it with rook a to okay well
look at that but if we're k2 which might
be like the first type of thing that you
look at now you see that after Rick gage
for blacks gonna be doing quite well
here because you can't play King anyone
because there were cage one so you're
just gonna have to get closer to the
fire and then we're gonna bring our
other look into the fray and yeah you're
gonna lose right we'll bring our other
rook into the fray with like work a fade
and then Rick f6 and yeah you won't be
able to contest the two rocks it's a
kind of unusual example of rook mating
in the endgame so instead of after work
at four c3 was played to kind of make
sure that at least now you're not going
to lose your work on anyone and now work
the d8 was played another possibility
here was to kind of try to run away with
a king and now black has a really nice
move which it's kind of counterintuitive
it's a bit of a computer move but it's
still worth showing because it's kind of
cool
so basically white ones we try to like
move over here so how can we stop him
from doing that Bishop e6 is one way but
there's like another way that is even
more per at all he's not only stopped
king d2 it even stops king
see three bishop seeking z2 ideas yeah
we're t8 is a really cool looking you
move yeah but you made six looks good
too and basically the idea now is if you
try to play king d2 rook takes you for
and and ricky to is coming and it's just
it's goodbye so this is a good lesson in
like when your opponent gives you some
material don't take it right away always
and said you can just continue to
pressure them with all these like
brilliant moves
so instead c3 and now worked the eight
anyway
and now after d4 there's a cool
variation here to after work h4 kini one
black to move and win another cool
computer ask variation yeah bishop desi
four years of bone cruncher and after
pawn takes before you can't you can't
stop work h1 mating yeah you can you can
throw in a couple of checks what do we
what do we call checks like this yeah we
call them spike checks right ain't just
like take a couple checks one more and
then get checkmate but well there's just
ok so instead let me just show the end
of the game and instead uh the game
ended like like this and now after c5
this is it up sort of really cool move
c5 basically white one black wants to
play Ricky to but in this particular
position if we play Ricky to work me to
you know kind of hangs on right so when
you play c5 you're creating all this
pressure this pawn can't take because of
the pin and if the knight takes
Ricky to now is coming in with
devastating effect we're just I'm gonna
play work the to check and then we're
gonna bring this work in and
more checkmates in the endgame right so
totally over a really really nice game
I'm Agnes like it's kind of amazing how
this end game I'll turn around so badly
for Fabiana but to go back to the
question in poppy Anna wasn't some time
pressure here or understandably because
there was a lot to figure out earlier so
Bishop takes up for the critical mistake
now players on the amateur level usually
their mistakes are around captures so
it's interesting that even in this elite
Grandmaster game by the number two
player in the world the mistake centers
on a CAPTCHA so that that really shows
you every time you're making a capture
in chess we're offering a capture stakes
her a little higher think about it a
little more well king h2 is just a good
move now because what can you do you 92
with the idea of g1 and it work takes up
to now like now I have time to take this
pawn right so you can't do that
you keep there's no good way for you to
bring your work in if you play eight six
then that cuts off your work up idea if
you played Bishop at six which will
probably be the most dangerous move now
I can play Bishop h6 and you still
aren't getting in right by the way if
you play Bishop g7 I'm not trading
because if I trade then again you'll be
able to play work out six to Rick h6
that Rover so instead of treating I'd
play what Bishop back to g5 but you see
that discipline it takes when your
opponent offers you a trade you say no
sometimes it's hard you know how people
don't like always like to do that
because it fuels it feels good to trade
but bad thing and you know you get a
check feels like you feel this like
momentary happiness from all these
things happening but then suddenly
you're like wait a second
it wasn't worth it the moments are
chakra now so yeah that could have saved
him
and you can see why it looks kind of
scary putting your king on h2 like that
but he's able to hang on because there's
just not a lot of entry squares so
really nice performance by Magnus
Carlsen who is showing that he is uh you
know the clear number one player in the
world right I mean he's a nice she's
doing quite well as well but especially
in terms of the World Rankings and his
number one reading spot which there was
a lot of distance then at the scene
field cop a little last you know magnus
continuing the kind of white in that gap
again